[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and an unofficial English
translation for chapter 104 was released
and I'm extremely excited to talk about
it we won't have a lot of manga panels
here so we can get the review out to you
as soon as possible
but also because we don't want to risk
the video being taken down since as you
know that happens but I am totally going
to go over what happens in the chapter
and my thoughts on it so stay tuned for
all of that if you're new to this
channel don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification bell so you
never miss an attack on titan video
attack on titan season 3 is gonna be
epic and you can expect a lot more
attack on titan content in the future
thanks again for the insane response
that my nineteen's and their powers
explained video received it was the
first video on this channel to ever hit
over 1 million views like that's insane
and it really means a lot if you love
the attack on titan content give that
like button a colossal smash and let's
do this
we start the chapter with armies
colossal titan last chapter he took out
enemy ships with the colossal things
unique explosion ability now he turns
back into his human form reminisces
about been told since he does to an
extent have his memories and notices the
familiar scenery an airship appears
above him and we cut to the action last
chapter gene was about to shoot peek and
falco came to beg for her life
gene is about to shoot falco and misses
he wonders if the steam that came from
Peaks titan altered his aim or if he
missed on purpose clearly gene likely
among a number of other survey corps
members still has trouble taking human
life then we get to meet us on aaron
fighting pork when his jaw tightened
form we see an amazing punch by Aaron's
attack Titan right to Porco's face but
as soon as you thought he landed an
amazing blow porco being as skilled as
he is catches his fist in his mouth and
destroys Aaron's hardened knuckles with
his extremely powerful jaw and closes
the distance between them it is quite
impressive how Porco turns Aaron's own
attack against Porco starts scratching
Aaron with his extremely powerful nails
like crazy scratch
Wolverine style and even makes dents in
the Warhammer Titans crystal now this is
a big deal because we haven't really
seen damage come to the crystal before
Aaron tried biting through it and it
didn't even leave a scratch so this
moment really shows how strong poor
kigali art and the jaw Titan can be his
jaw and nails are significantly more
powerful to normal hardened Titan skin
and they can even theoretically cut a
crystallized Titan user out of their
crystal which is crazy powerful if we
think about it
what's more mucosal notices that along
with his powerful jaw nails
he is extremely fast much more so than
Ymir's jaw Titan was I mean the fact
that he could dodge Mikasa so
effortlessly is very impressive if
anything this chapter up to this point
has really highlighted how formidable
the jaw Titan can be despite its small
size it looks like Aaron might have been
a goner if Mika still did not say I'm in
the nick of time
leaving Aaron's Titans face horribly
disfigured but still breathing also Eren
attained the extremely valuable
information that the crystallized Titan
user is not untouchable and the jaw
Titan power is one key to cutting
through the crystal this means that if
they took the jaw Titans power they
could penetrate through Annie's crystal
perhaps it son carefully the jaw Titan
power could even remove the Titan user
from their crystal without harming the
user too much either way we need to know
what's going on with Annie it's been so
long we also learned that the car Titan
cannot endure attacks very well
especially when compared to the armored
Titan Gabby and Falco look over peaks
injured body they say that the pace of
her healing cannot even keep up with a
serious injury which is scary because
out of everyone from our lay I really do
like Peake a lot suddenly something
shocks everyone Connie says very on time
which is interesting and we see what
appears to be a Zeppelin or airship at
first I thought oh [ __ ] back up for
Marlay but then we see hanji herself
which is extremely exciting oh how I've
missed this mad genius now we learn what
the lights were being set up for it
wasn't the guide Armin and his cool
or Colossus Titan explosion but to guide
the Zeppelin then we have this Elango
bull guy helping hanji and he appears to
be wearing a marl a military outfit and
sweating a bit not sure if they somehow
forced along gobo to help them but it
seems like he's going along with Han
geez playing without a problem
Arman is also there on the ship and
they're planning to bring the ship low
enough so that every one of our guys can
board it what an incredible entrance by
Han Jie I have to say let me know if
you're psyched to see Han Jie again in
the comments below
and if there's anyone else you are still
itching to see any it is then revealed
that this was Armin's genius yet
extremely risky plan Arman thinks it's
worth the risk of being shot down since
if everyone doesn't get on they'll have
no future anyways guys this shit's
getting real Galliard or poor KO tries
to destroy the airship and my best girl
Mika son manages to predict his move and
cuts his legs then Erinn takes advantage
of the opportunity and slams Porco on
the ground now something really
interesting happens as we already saw
Porco's nails were strong and sharp
enough to cut the crystal so Erin
assumes that his jaw the key
characteristic of the jaw Titan will be
able to crush the crystal so he shoves
the warhammer tighten into Porco's mouth
and pushes Porco's jaw together erin was
correct and assuming that the jaw was
strong enough and the crystal begins to
crack Porco can't believe it and the
Warhammer Titan definitely looks
concerned and then Aaron actually
manages to consume the Warhammer Titan
possessor unreal I gotta say I didn't
think this chapter would be this
action-packed and then as if it wasn't
enough
Eren turfs to Galliard just as Aaron is
about to bite into Porco's Titans nape
Reiner gets up because of Falco and
Gabby who are cheering him on I feel
like Aaron had enough time to bite
through the jaw Titans nape here but he
chooses to get a good punch on Reiner
while he still can instead now people
might be like why would he do that
instead of just getting the jaw Titan
power - but he tells me kasaa that he's
already out of stress
so he probably would not have been able
to defend himself against Reiner if he
tried to consume Porco at that point but
let me know what you guys think
as a result Reiner manages to save Porco
and our inner wall dwellers start to
make their escape Aaron says that
they're still not gonna be able to kill
Reiner this time but he seems to like
that pure hatred that he had for him a
while ago it seems like he can empathize
more with him than he could before which
makes sense because he's seen rider's
world and where he was coming from and
how horrible he feels after everything
that happened however all of Aaron's
previous rage seems to have passed over
to Gabby Gabby loses her cool as young
Aaron was prone to do and she says I
will kill them all just like Aaron used
to say that he would kill all the Titans
it very much looks like the cycle of
hatred is starting anew and will
continue at this point but we'll have to
wait and see now the question that we
are left with is will our guys
successfully escape or be shot down in
my view one way or another they're
escaping but without the jaw tightened
power they still might not be able to
touch an E Plus probably the craziest
news of the whole chapter
Aaron gained a new Titan power Aaron is
along with the founding Titan along with
the attack Titan the new Warhammer Titan
that Titan who seemed to have just
appeared a little while ago is already
gone has been consumed by Aaron now it
is going to be exciting to learn more
about the Warhammer Titans powers
alongside Aaron perhaps the Warhammer
Titans powers will allow them to break
into Annie's crystal again we'll have to
wait and see but wow what an insane
chapter guys I don't know what to say
the story has really come a long way
hopefully we'll get to finally see
parodies now but the time we spent in
Marlay was definitely eye-opening I mean
I am still more on air and Mekas on Levi
side but you have to at least empathize
with the Aldean's of Marlay although I
know some of you don't or can't but they
are either doing what they're doing to
protect their family or because they
have been brainwashed and don't know any
better
what about Zeke after saying he's not
enemies with Aaron Levi just killed him
and that's the end of that no way I feel
like they might be bringing Zeke's human
form with them on the airship and
hopefully we'll finally figure out what
Zeke's planning
alright guys wow like I said we have
definitely come a long way tell me do
you want to stay in Marlay more or are
you like me and want to go to paradise
again is there anything you're wondering
about currently or do you have any
theories about what it's going to happen
next let me know in the comments below
just want to also take this time near
the end of the video to explain that ana
Mack my brother and fellow anime uproar
youtuber usually does these reviews but
he's in Cuba on vacation and since I
already did the first two attack on
Titan reviews we ever did on this
channel I thought it was my duty to come
out of a review retirement and do this
one too especially since this chapter
was frickin insane I haven't been making
as many videos because I'm currently in
grad school doing my masters in English
and writing tons of essays and doing
tons of presentations and so on I've
been helping out behind the scenes and
you guys can always reach me on our
Instagram account at Anime uproar but I
really want to shout out Anna Mac for
taking on a lot of the work himself
while I'm finishing this degree and
thank all of you guys
whether you joined us over the summer
when I first started making attack on TV
do zand stuck all the way through or
even if you just subscribed your support
means a lot guys and I'll be done the
masters soon enough and then me and Anna
Mack will be going full-time on YouTube
creating the best content that we can
for you guys I know everyone says that
they have the best subscribers but those
guys are filthy liars because you guys
are the best stay tuned and look out for
a lot of anime content in the upcoming
years until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]